reviens on vient toujours là dessus dans
les transports vous avez votre masque
vous portez votre masque mais je dis qu
il n'y a pas vraiment de doutes sur
sujet en fait comme si c'était une
discussion mais on sait très bien que
les contaminations à ce fonds dans les
soirées dans les bars et ans et qui a
pas de contamination dans les collèges
des lycées les transports ce qu'on
avance on assassine et ça s'est avéré
vain le ministre vers ans il a pas fait
ces choses là comme ça parce qu'il s'est
dit dans les bars ont fait la fed 22h à
la il n'a pas fait les choses comme ça y
est après six ans que j'ai débordé la
tuer et à autre chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre sur cette épidémie ce qu'en
fait la plupart des gens contamine
personnes 90 % des gens vous nous
transmettez de virus à personne mais à
dix pour cent des gens qui contamine
tout le monde d'accord comme ça que ça
se passe
en fait quelques soirées sa relance
l'épidémie donc c'est pas chacun va
faire ses petites contamination dans son
entourage
ces quelques personnes qui vont relancer
l' épidémie en corée il ya un seul mec
cas relancer l'épidémie dans séoul parce
qu'il a fait dit bart et la contaminer
des centaines de personnes c'est ça les
comportements c'est à dire qu'en fait
c'est un virus de la fête mais des
grosses fêtes c'est pas un virus du
métro c'est pas un virus c'est pourtant
ce que vous niez voilà c'est ça c'est
pour ça que si jamais on est vite ça
doit pouvoir vivre quasi normalement et
au collège et au lycée ya pas de poster
je dire y'a pas eu des explosions de
d'épidémie couler les collégiens vont
dans des bars le soir cela [ __ ] et pas
par les collégiens ça passe par les gens
qui d'après moi des collégiens et des
lycéens viennent me voir et me dit il me
dise clairement
des fois il ya des classes avec deux
élèves m'a dit j'ai pas nier qu'il y
avait aucun collégiens qui j'ai dit que
les gens qui transmettent les mines et
on le sait c'est à partir de 18 jusqu'à
28 ans et à partir de rouler jamais il
ya des lycéens qui sont aussi celles qui
sont contaminés ou les lycées un
d'occasion qui vont en fête le samedi
soir et qui arrive le lundi qui sont
peut-être contaminés oui mais ils vont
aimer la transmission le dire c'est vrai
dans les soirées
la transmission se fait non mais déjà
c'est à dire que si vous voulez
transmettre il faut aller dans les
soirées boursiers ne riez pas dans les
soirées un sommet dans l'histoire un cap
les deux virus donc les soirées c'est le
fléau et bien sûr les stars et les
campus docteur il ya des étudiants en ce
moment il ya même des des campus qui
essayent de terre les clusters qui sont
nés sans dans leur université
vous êtes en train de nous dire que les
étudiants en ce moment que c'est en
train de se transmettre le virus
ils risquent rien ça se transmet le
faire a dit que j'avais aucune
transmission j'ai dit que la plupart des
transmissions passer par les soirées
pourquoi en espagne il on explique
qu'une explosion épidémique ce parce
qu'ils ont fait la fête à barcelone dans
les bars sur la costa brava
c'est tout on le sait et à partir du
arrêtez d'ouvrir les bars de nuit et les
boîtes de nuit ils ont commencé à
étendre aulas dans la ligne 13 quand on
voit les gens en train de tenir les bars
de métro etc
dans les études il ya aucune
condamnation dans les cinq marques dans
le métro c'est pas là que ça passe que
vous soyez dans un endroit clos tu vous
parlait fort que vous chantiez vous
soyez avec tout le monde sait ça
l'ambiance de la transmission du virus
c'est pas vous passer un quart d'heure
dans un métro où vous êtes masqué c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe
moi je vous donne ce qu'on ce qu'on sait
c'est gabriel a tassé vous avez un le
conseil c'est ce qui vous a dit le
conseil des médecins mais bien sûr je
pense est important qu'il soit là et
qu'ils le disent parce que forcément
quand c'est le gouvernement sa cellule
c'est toujours suspect maintenant quand
les politiques il fait pas partie du
tout du goût et non pas du tout et il va
d'ailleurs se dit non et d'ailleurs vous
avez avant que moi j'ai été très
critique mois gérard larcher que le
masque en extérieur ce n'était pas utile
j'ai pensé que tester tracé isolée
c'était une bêtise j'ai toujours dit
qu'on aurait dû porter le masque avant
et que ans n'a pas été du sittomat
j'étais extrêmement critique mais en
revanche fermeture des bars et des
restaurants pour contrôler l'épidémie je
suis désolé mais c'est la seule chose
qui va marcher et fermé les collèges et
les lycées ça va empêcher les élèves
d'aller au collège et au lycée et ça
servira à rien